we've got a big bernie day today for you
a lot of Bernie Sanders related news and
we're going to start with his a very
very interesting Fox News Town Hall last
night I have watched a lot of
presidential town halls already just
this year and also over the last many
elections some go well some not so well
sort of depends on the candidates
preparation and their personality has a
lot to do with it and last night Bernie
Sanders had this town hall on Fox News
which he dominated in a way that I
cannot recall seeing another politician
dominate and it wasn't perfect and I'm
gonna give you the good and I'm gonna
give you the not-so-good in a moment but
there were sort of two main arguments
leading up to this about whether Bernie
Sanders should or shouldn't appear the
argument against Bernie appearing is a
very simple one which is Fox News is the
propaganda arm of the Trump
administration it is not going to be a
town hall that is sort of fairly set up
it is going to be an audience that is
going to have hand-picked people from
political groups including turning-point
USA which happened it's going to be one
that most likely will turn into a
two-on-one sort of argument between two
Fox News moderators and Bernie Sanders
which it did and it's a net loss don't
give them the ratings by appearing that
was the argument against Bernie
appearing on the other side the argument
for Bernie appearing is listen these are
people who otherwise may never even get
a real understanding from Bernie himself
about what his policies are most people
not in the physical audience but in the
Fox News television audience probably
are not going to be voting for the
Democrat in November of 2020 but if
Bernie can convince just 1 or 2 percent
of the people in the audience it's
worthwhile and he could reach people
that otherwise will never have anything
break their echo-chamber pierce their
propaganda and therefore it's worth
Bernie appearing both the respectable
and defensible points of view I've
tended to take the latter approach when
Fox News has invited me I know they're
gonna give me crappy lighting I know
they're going to talk over me and turn
down my mic and make it a two-on-one
debate against me but I still do it
because I think I could actually reach
some people that seems to have been
Bernie's approach and he did it and it
really was incredible
Brett Bayer and Martha McCallum were the
hosts or I guess you could call the
moderators and they were just completely
out of their league and completely
outclassed by Bernie Sanders there were
just multiple attempts to try to frame
questions in an unfair way Bernie didn't
let them force him into answering the
questions when they were loaded or
unfair he would reset and explain the
problem with the questions as asked
which is a great thing to be able to do
Bernie Sanders had extraordinary control
and facility with the issues in a way
that Brett Bayer and Martha McCallum
simply did not it's the sort of thing
where you don't have to agree with all
of Bernie's policies but the way he
handled this should be part of a
political science department seminar on
how to handle opposition biased
questions in these political media
events we're going to start with this is
what I call the healthcare Fiasco with
Martha McCallum she just completely
embarrassed herself this was already
after several minutes of back-and-forth
on the topic of health care which was
talked about quite a bit during the
townhall and this was after the crowd
loudly proclaimed that they would gladly
switch from private insurance to
Medicare for all and Martha McAllen just
totally steps in it has no clue what's
going on her head is spinning she
doesn't even know what she's talking
about here do you think that's how we
should spend help I think everybody is
an agreement that healthcare needs to be
fixed in this country the question is
how and my question to you was it will
drive up taxes to pay for health care
and not just the wealthy will pay for
that the middle class will also pay for
ego so how do you justify it and Martha
what are you not including in your
discussion you time I will tell you
you're not got any health insurance
premiums
[Applause]
your payroll tax right look Healthcare
is not free you never suggest that we're
gonna March you just said it was gonna
be free for everyone it's gonna be free
at the point of when you use it okay in
you go - why are you so shocked by this
this is what it's all about here's good
boy okay okay one one side rush we'll
get through this together so Bernie
Sanders visibly struggling to contend
with martha maccallum signora's on this
issue and immediately online people
started claiming look at Bernie
mansplaining - Martha McCallum give me a
break he was explaining to her how the
real world works no one says that
single-payer is printing money is
growing money on trees rather it's
exactly right you pay for it one way or
the other as martha maccallum points out
the cheaper way the more efficient way
is through taxation and a single-payer
system then brett bayer after all of
this asks maybe the dumbest question
i've seen during a town hall ever which
is will members of Congress get
something else instead of what Bernie
Sanders is proposing for health care and
obviously Bernie Sanders says now why
would that be the case we are saying to
that family of four
you ain't gonna pave that 28000 you're
not paying any more premiums you're not
paying any more co-payments you're not
paying any more deductibles how's that
28000 you're not paying but does that
mean you're not gonna pay something of
course it does you're gonna pay more in
taxes and do members of Congress you now
have gold-plated health insurance well
they have a special plan that's outside
Obamacare a different plan you know do
member of members of Congress are they
going to do that transition is a right
of course totally farcical failed gotcha
question and this was the theme just
every gotcha question backfiring on
Martha and Brett Martha McCallum making
a fool of herself later when Bernie says
felons should have the right to vote he
says they've committed crimes they can
sit in prison their entire
lives but any movement to curtail voting
rights is bad she says well isn't that
just because you want felons to vote for
you and Bernie just laughs it off as the
ridiculous question that it is so what's
you thought it's like you committed a
crime you can't vote well you did this
you can't vote you did that you can't
vote I don't like that
every American a teen of age of older
who's a citizen in this country has the
right to vote oh come on
and you have done a scientific study
that everybody wants to you know
encourage orange motors one of the one
of the great problems actually Martha
not everyone wants to encourage voting
that's the problem we're dealing with
and the audience rightly booing her for
the ridiculous question and burly Bernie
Bernie truly destroying almost every
question not all which I will get to but
really an extraordinary performance in a
place that often doesn't get this kind
of sense talked into them I'm talking
about Fox News fantastic rant by Bernie
about the military-industrial complex
and all of the difficult problems that
he's solving and Bret Baier if you're
watching looks punch-drunk he doesn't
know what hit him
you got hundreds of thousands of bright
young people in America today the
wealthiest country in the world they
can't afford to go to college and you've
got 40 million people struggling with
student debt you really think that we
cannot do better as a nation and on top
of that you got a handful of people who
own more wealth than the bottom half of
the American Society no I understand
that we're taking on corporate America
we're taking on the Republicans of
making on the Democratic establishment
taking on the drug companies taking on
the insurance companies take it on the
military industrial complex you know
what
the ladies I know that
but I think what the American people
know the American people I think are
ready to deal with justice in America
that's that's what we're fighting for
very very well handled it got to the
topic of late term abortion immediately
Bernie went to the right answer which is
the idea of late term abortion abortion
of the day before a full term would
would be over and a baby would be born
it's extraordinarily rare it's become
politicized and he just doesn't let them
frame the debate you said yesterday I
watched her rally in Pittsburgh that no
one should tell a woman what you do with
her own body proportion do you believe
that a woman should be able to terminate
a pregnancy up until the moment of birth
look I think that that happens very very
rarely and I think this is being made
into a political issue okay so I think
it's rare it's being made into a
political issue but at the end of the
day I believe that the decision over
abortion belongs to a woman and a
physician not the federal government not
the state absolutely spot on this is not
I'm eight and a half months pregnant you
know what on the other hand I think I'd
rather not have a kid in go jet skiing
for the next 18 years Bernie's a hundred
percent right to diffuse it and to not
let them force him to answer it on their
terms asked about congresswoman Eleanor
Mar very well handled you are looking to
become the first Jewish president you're
also a staunch supporter of
congresswoman Ilhan Omar
oh I just talked the Ilhan about twice
in my life so but if I respectfully need
support but now this is what I do
support I support a a Muslim member of
Congress not to be attacked every single
day in outrageous racist remarks sure my
question is that even some fellow
Democrats had some problems have accused
of you her of using language kind of
associated with anti-semitism can you
understand why some Jewish Americans
would have a problem but with some of
them I can understand I think that that
is not quite right and I think that
Ilana has got to do maybe a better job
in speaking to the Jewish community but
if you if your question to me as though
I think she is anti-semitic no I don't
know it's not her I'm saying in the
thread but here is the point also I'm
Jewish
our boss my father's family was
devastated by Hitler so this is an issue
of some sensitivity to me so I will do
everything in my power and I hope that
every member of Congress will fight not
only anti-semitism but racism and
anti-muslim activity so that we create a
non-discriminatory society but it is not
anti-semitic to be critical of a
right-wing government in Israel
absolutely spot-on my position
she didn't say anti-semitic things we're
not saying she's anti-semitic
criticizing the right-wing netanyahu
government is a progressive thing to do
but she may have to do a better job of
speaking to the Jewish community very
very well said by Bernie nothing extra
not allowing them to use these framed
loaded questions lastly is Joe Biden a
progressive another dumb gotcha question
which Bernie doesn't take the bait on
the audience laughs at how dumb the
question is Joe Biden is a progressive
look
Joe is somebody who I have known for
many many years Joe is a friend of mine
and by the way I hope very much that in
the Democratic primary we got a lot of
good people many of them personal
friends of mine that we have a debate
about the issues and not about personal
really hard-hitting question how is Joe
Biden a progressive so that's the good
now it wasn't all perfect for Bernie
I've said for a while Bernie's weakest
area is foreign policy and he sort of
fumbled through the primary foreign
policy question which was who is our
biggest geopolitical foe or enemy or
whatever not his strongest moment from a
foreign policy perspective which country
is the biggest threat to the US I don't
know that I look I don't like using the
word threat because I says oh my god we
have to spend millions more on the
Million example clearly you know we are
concerned about China and we're
concerned about Russia but here's the
irony here you got people who say we
need to spend even more than 700 billion
dollars a year more than the next 10
nations combined on the military you
know why cuz I China is a real potential
enemy these are the same people who are
investing billions of dollars building
the Chinese economy I find that somewhat
ironic all right so I don't like to use
the word enemy clearly we need a strong
defense we need to bring the United
States and the rest of the world
together do everything we can to rid
this world of nuclear weapons and I'll
tell you what else in my view is a
national security issue and that is we
have God as a nation to reject Trump's
idea that climate change is a hopes
instead of sort of fumbling around and
then getting to the climate change hoax
as dangerous I would have said listen me
listing countries an order of threat is
playground politics it's childish it's
counterproductive diplomatically it's
potentially self-destructive I'm not
going to do that there are countries
that don't have our best interests in
mind your elected officials know who
they are our intelligence agencies know
who they are but what I want to tell you
today is that any country that doesn't
take climate change seriously as a top
priority is part of the problem there
danger not just to the United States
they're a danger to homosapians on this
planet and under my administration we
will no longer be one of those countries
that's how I would have handled that he
sort of got to climate change but not in
the best way one other sort of misstep
was when he was asked why not just pay
more taxes yourself which is one of the
dumbest right-wing anti-tax questions -
your thoughts - Joseph on your taxes do
show that you're a millionaire you did
make a million 2016-2017 you're right
the 561 and 2018 but your marginal tax
rate was 26% because of President
Trump's tax cuts so why not say you know
I'm leading this revolution I'm not
gonna take those but during the I am I
paid the taxes that I go and by the way
once you got Donald Trump up here and
asked him how much he pays in taxes yeah
so he's sort of stumbled I would have
better off have been said uh in in the
way of listenmi spending extra cut of
checks to the IRS isn't policy you don't
run government with the idea that I'm
just gonna cut a random check to the IRS
that they're not even budgeting for or
would have a particular a plan for use
it's silly to suggest that we govern by
policy here not by activists cutting
checks to the IRS overall excellent
performance people tweeting me saying
what do you mean Bernie destroyed or
wanted it's a town hall he wasn't
against anyone if you watched it you
would have realized it was Bernie two on
one against two FoxNews clowns and I
think it was smart of Bernie to
generally limit attacks on Trump for the
Fox News audience because remember even
though right now he's trying to win the
primary the Fox News audience is more
likely only to be deciding about whether
to vote for Bernie
if Bernie makes it to the general
election so I think it was smart not to
go crazy just harping on Donald Trump
excellent performance if you disagree
let me know I'm on Twitter at D Pakman
the show is on twitter at david pakman
show one of the day's sponsors is
privacy comm slash Pakman which is a
free service that I myself use really
useful in many different ways takes just
a few seconds to link your debt
card to privacy calm then you can create
virtual credit cards that are linked
directly to your bank account and you
use those virtual credit card numbers to
buy things online which protects your
actual debit card so that it's not
spread all over the Internet and one of
the best things about it is how their
mobile app and browser extensions for
Chrome and Firefox make it really easy
to use let's say for example that I'm
signing up for a david pakman show
membership in the credit card number
field I already see the privacy com icon
I just click it choose which of my
virtual credit cards I want to use and
the credit card number expiration date
and security code are automatically
entered I can put in any zip code I want
and I'm done and if you try to use my
credit card number that you just saw on
the screen it doesn't matter because
I've already deleted that virtual card
and that's the beauty of privacy comm
there are a ton of advantages to using a
free service like this for example you
can sign up for as many free trials as
you want then just delete the virtual
credit card you used and never worry
about getting charged for it it protects
you from getting hacked it protects you
when companies are hacked which happens
all the time it is all completely free
all you have to do is click the link
under this video to get started and for
a limited time they're giving everyone
in our audience $5 towards your first
purchase when you sign up using that
link